we are defending our future the future
of our kids the uk thinks it can avoid
world war iii and i truly hope it can
but i think leaders need to work harder
and unify and you know face up to the
bully that is putin
we get stronger here every day
it gets easier we will be definitely
they are trying to
undermine our morale and boost in
ukraine hitting the civilian people but
we will never give up will not fall for
any of the provocations ever
because i'm in contact with my other
part of family in moscow as well
and they are able to find loopholes and
they are not scared and they still
brainwashed and there is no way of
breaking that wall absolutely no way
it's just it's been
for generations since primary school age
that they've been told lies
and it's really hard to get the message
there
well i think i would stand in front of
him and say mr putin look deeply into
your heart
you claim that you are an orthodox
christian
in your conscience you are hearing god
saying stop this war stop the aggression
and let your name be known as the man
who brought peace to the world become
known as a peacemaker not a man who
brought further pain and destruction
[Music]
if you had just one wish for this whole
situation what would stop the war stops
the war
foreign